quartier populaire de valier casse
aujourd'hui 200 personnes sont
rassemblées pour une commémoration en
mémoire des millions de victimes de la
shoah
la rue
au milieu des nombreux juifs
pilar heredia une gitane de 45 ans cet
ancien secrétaire d'état aux minorités
ethniques du gouvernement sa patte héros
assiste discrètement à la cérémonie nous
allumons cette bougie pour le peuple
gitan sintis et roms
pour ceux qui ont survécu pour ceux qui
sont morts nous n'oublierons pas vos
noms pilar et la toute première gitane à
avoir été élu au sein d'un gouvernement
espagnol comme chaque année elle vient
honorer la mémoire des trois cent mille
gitans massacrés pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale partout en europe
un pan de l'histoire souvent ignoré ce
type de commémoration devrait avoir lieu
spécifiquement pour les gitans pas une
cérémonie partager mais une
commémoration réellement pour nous on
nous a oubliés dans l'histoire on nous
oublie toujours on ne se souvient jamais
de ce qui est arrivé au peuple gitan
aujourd'hui seuls quelques minutes ont
été accordées aux victimes gitane
persécutés dès 1939 par les nazis mais
aussi par le dictateur local le général
franco
les jus ils sont bien organisés mais
nous oui nous on est toujours en fin de
cortège dans ce genre de commémoration
on est toujours les invisibles
partout on établit fils c'est ce qui
nous fait le plus mal
on est en train de lutter pour être
visible et on n'y arrive pas la
visibilité des gitans c'est le combat
quotidien de pilar c'est dans son
appartement du quartier sol qu'on la
retrouve ce soir en espagne 88% des
gitans sont sédentarisés conséquences
d'un rejet profond du nomadisme dans la
société
allez allez débarrasse on enlève sa de
la pilar joue à fond la carte de
l'intégration chemise ouverte et chaînes
en or qui brille trop ces manuels le
fils de pilar le hors série comme
l'appellent ses profs est le premier des
50 militants de la capitale a intégré
une grande fac madrilène je suis très
fier mais ça me fait de la peine de voir
que je suis le seul gitans
c'est pas parce qu'on est des gitans on
a moins de capacités intellectuelles
pour pouvoir faire une carrière
je lui dis bravo dans quelques temps il
sera un grand policier espagnol pagnol
siros emmanuel rêve de devenir flic
ntone l'un des trois autres fils de
pilar n'aspire qu'à la musique et à la
gloire
financé par papa il veut lancer un album
fusion du michael jackson à la sauce
flamenco c'est sa recette pour se faire
entendre
là mon petit à la musique ça a été un
instrument d'intégration pour les gitans
ça nous ouvre les portes de la société
aujourd'hui si je vais juste chanter du
flamenco personne ne me remarque mais
maintenant quand je me présente avec la
fusion
michael jackson flamenco les gens ne
remarquent beaucoup plus les gitans en
espagne cinq siècles d'une très lente
intégration mais à l'instar de pilar et
de ses enfants
la route risque d'être encore longue
[Musique]
à madrid le flamenco l'âme des gitans
c'est le vecteur d'intégration dans
l'avs à pièce le quartier historique la
musique gitane aux andalouses résonne le
long de petits cafés concerts les
tablaos
non
visite christique et charisme naturel
diego el cigala est l'un des plus
célèbres cantaor de flamenco c'est dans
l'une de ses tavernes qu'il a débuté sa
carrière j'ai toujours aimé m'entourer
de gens qui ont du feeling une vraie
histoire
si tu as à tout roule
mais si tu n'as pas ça tu peux atteindre
la lumière est temps d'aller en novembre
2010 le flamenco a été reconnue par
l'unesco au patrimoine mondial
immatériel de l'humanité
une récompense tardive pour la
communauté
[Musique]
hulu grand flammes et une piste allait
chanter à la porte des bourgeois ils se
fatiguent et juste pour un petit bout de
pain et quand il avait ce petit bout de
pain c'était déjà une grande récompense
pour eux dieu merci ils nous ont mis sur
un petit piédestal mais ça aurait dû
être fait bien avant mais nesta n'ont
pas
le lendemain c'est à elle bosquet la
banlieue chic de madrid que nous
retrouvons diego dans un studio aménagé
dans les combles de sa maison il
peaufine son dernier album il y a
quelques mois la star du flamenco à
débuter une nouvelle carrière celle de
producteur
un pas de géant chez des gitans
longtemps cantonné à un simple rôle de
saltimbanques avance n'était pas
habituel ça ne se faisait pas aucun gîte
en avaient les moyens d'avoir un studio
d'enregistrement
c'était difficile de commencer il n'y
avait pas la technologie d'aujourd'hui
il n'y avait pas non plus d'un chanteur
qui s'auto produisait bercé au flamenco
par son papa
diego tente aujourd'hui de passer le
flambeau à son plus jeune fils raphaël
cinq ans
[Musique]
c'est quoi ton nom ton nom de scène
c'est quoi le petit 13 heures je pense
que c'est très important c'est bien
qu'un de tes enfants - suivre tes
parents t'ont pas son nom je lui
transmets cette énergie je ne le force
pas je lui donne des conseils quand on
écoute du flamenco l'huile regardez
écoutez ça rentre tout seul dans sa tête
diego la cigale peut dormir sur ses deux
oreilles
la relève est assurée
[Musique]
le flamenco le chante même sur les bancs
de l'église alors comme tous les soirs
pilar se rendant leur astro le quartier
gitan pour le culte évangéliste de sa
communauté
[Musique]
regard seniors gloire au seigneur amen
on remercie dieu cet après midi comme
tous les jours pour nous permettre
d'être avec lui la foi chevillée au
corps pilar est un modèle tous en
profite ici pour lui demander conseil
c'est le cas de rosario dont la fille a
une scolarité perturbée en espagne deux
tiers des gitans de plus de 16 ans n'ont
pas suivi un cursus scolaire classique
c'est moi qui lui ai appris à la maison
mon cheval de bataille c'est de dire au
pasteur qu'ils encouragent les parents
s'ils envoient leurs enfants à l'église
tous les jours ils peuvent les envoyer à
l'école en 2008 pilar a été remercié de
son poste de secrétaire d'état
après avoir dénoncé une certaine inertie
au sein du parti socialiste espagnol
pendant les campagnes électorales
tout le monde se penche sur la question
gitane mais bon on ne se sent représenté
par aucun parti en espagne
on n'a pas de parlementaires gitans ni
de représentation politique et d'avions
pour les dégâts en héritage
un vrai paradoxe les 800000 gitans
d'espagne intègre peu à peu la classe
moyenne est aujourd'hui 63 % d'entre eux
ont un emploi mais à l'instar de ses
voisins européens
le multikulti a aussi du mal à
fonctionner dans la marmite ibérique